[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم الحكومه الاسرائيليه
تعقد اجتماعا داخل نفق اسفل حائط البراق
والبلده القديمه في القدس
ونتنياهو يقول انما وصفها بمعركه توحيد
القدس لا تزال مستمره حماس تصف الاجتماع
بالتصعيد الخطير لما وصفتها بحرب دينيه
على المدينه المقدسه وحركه فتح تشدد على
انه لن يغير من الحقيقه التاريخيه
والدينيه للقدس وتنديد واسع باقتحام
بنجفير باحات المسجد الاقصى بعد اعلان
الكريم وشركه فاجنر السيطره على كامل باخ
موت شرقيه اوكرانيا الجيش الاوكراني يؤكد
انه يفرض حصارا جزئيا على المدينه
وزيلينسكي يجدد دعوته للحصول على مقاتلات
اف 16 في ختام قمتها في هيروشيما مجموعه
السبع تؤكد دعم اوكرانيا خلال الحرب
الروسيه عليها وتحذر الصين من تداعيات
الاقدام على اي تصرف ضد تايوان
تقول انها قرارات القمه تهدف لاحتواء
روسيا والصين وبجين تتهم المجموعه بزعزعه
الاستقرار وتجاهل بواعث القلق الصيني
اتفاق جديد في جده السعوديه لوقف اطلاق
النار في السودان من اجل ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه واشنطن تقول ان الاتفاق سيسمح
بوصول المساعدات ويوفر طريقا لوقف دائم
للاعمال العدائيه الى اللقاء